nous sommes dans
une épreuve terrible qui est une guerre
en ukraine et qui
justifie que l'on puisse savoir du côté
de la france la meilleure réponse
celle qui à la fois garantir notre
sécurité permet aussi aux valeurs que
nous portons d'être défendus et du lien
que nous avons avec l'ukraine j'ai eu
comme président de la république à
connaître de ce lourd dossier de
l'ukraine au moment des accords de minsk
je connais les buts que se sont donnés
les dirigeants russes et notamment
vladimir poutine
c'est à dire
faire que l'ukraine
puisse être démantelé
et qu'elle puisse être neutralisée
au prix
d'un désastre pour la population civile
et et d'un conflit qui restera ouvert
pendant de longues années donc face à
cette menace face à cet objectif que
poursuit vladimir poutine il faut que
l'europe
la france
l'alliance atlantique soit à la hauteur
est d'abord d'élever le niveau des
sanctions c'est ce que j'ai dit au
président macron je considère qu' il
faut encore renforcer les sanctions et
notamment les sanctions financières ce
qu'on appelle aussi le système de
transactions monétaires de manière à ce
que la russie
pas sa population mais en tout cas son
économie et ses dirigeants puissent être
lourdement frappé par cette réponse
il nous faut aussi aider l'ukraine aider
sa population et des le président qui
est dans une situation extrêmement
difficile périlleuse même pour sa propre
vie et enfin il faut que les européens
se convainc que leur sécurité même si
elle est dans un réseau d'alliances avec
les états unis que leur sécurité est
d'abord leur affaire et que s'il ya une
conclusion déjà attiré à la veille d'une
élection présidentielle
c'est que
nous devons la france parce que nous
sommes le pays d'europe aujourd'hui de
l'union à 27 qui dispose de la force de
dissuasion qui siégeront comme membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité nous
devons la france convaincre nos amis
européens qu'ils doivent faire un effort
beaucoup plus conséquent pour leur
défense et à voir avec l'alliance
atlantique
un rapport qui puisse nous assurer que
notre sécurité sera garantie
je fais dernière observation c'est que
tous ceux qui ont mis en cause l'idée
même de l'alliance atlantique lille et
même d'une force de défense européenne
aujourd'hui dans le débat public
français doivent être appelés à la
responsabilité
dans les discussions avec la ville un
peu cul non moi je veux pas revenir sur
les épisodes précédents ce qui compte
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui ce qu'on
doit faire aujourd'hui c'est relever le
niveau des sanctions ce qui a été dit
hier n'est pas suffisant à la fois sur
le système monétaire sur système
financier et aussi sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz oui ça sera
plus coûteux et notamment pour nos amis
allemands de plus approvisionnée en gaz
russe
mais comment allait justifier qu'on
continue à acheter du gaz russe quand la
russie intervient militairement dans un
pays indépendant et créent des
souffrances terribles au peuple
ukrainien voilà ce que l'europe doit
faire c'est de se faire respecter il
n'ya pas diplomatie sans rapports de
force c'est d'avoir peut-être oublié
quelquefois que l'europe
a pu être considérée comme naïve c'est
pour ça que j'ai insistait sur
l'europe de la défense sur la nécessité
d'avoir des garanties de sécurité et sur
l'effort que chaque pays doit consentir
la france le fait pour assurer la
protection de sa population